remember Congress here we defer do you
believe the house passage of the know
war against Iran act yesterday will
effectively curb Trump's ability to take
military action without congressional
approval so this has always been a we
passed two resolutions one was ending
the 2002 AUMF the authorization to use
military why we got into Iraq right that
was widely seen as we got an that was
there was 2000 and the 2001 AUMF which
is fighting al Qaeda and terrorists so
we're fighting under that the 2002 AUMF
was largely seen as set out to take out
the Saddam Hussein regime that's the one
Biden's always having to explain his
vote for right that
so he's yes so I voted for us about the
only person to vote against not as a
representative barbara Lee from Oakland
oh I'm thinking of the one that many
like 27 Democratic senators voted for it
to give bush or thought up gay in the
house yeah okay in the house barb
representative barbara Lee was was the
only person to vote against that if I
recall correctly and um no I think
that's the one that was right after
Afghanistan I think more people were for
the Iraq war right because by then they
had sold it as okay and she led that
because appealed this one - mm - well
the house has house that house has their
won't pass the Senate it like I what you
would like it to I would like it to pass
the Senate because I don't think we need
these long outstanding authorizations to
use military force I think Congress has
abdicated many of its responsibilities
including it has respect to war power
forever and you know to have these
unending war powers out there you know I
think is we should definitely stop the
2002 AUMF I think we need to actually
modernize the 2001 AUMF but I've been
hesitant to repeal it I'm not
co-sponsoring that until we have a sense
of what a new authorization would look
like I think we need it like many people
that we need to find a pathway to ending
our
fight in Afghanistan and Iraq however I
don't think it's healthy for a country
to do that precipitously simply pull out
and then we voted to not authorize
funding for a war with Iran and
specifically saying the President does
not have the authorization to go to war
with Iran we had passed both of these as
amendments to the National Defense
Authorization Act they were both
stripped out in conference when we went
to conference with the Republican Senate
so we passed them both on the House
floor now okay Rick Wilson will the with
a Lincoln project formally endorsed a
candidate for 2020 Lincoln project is
you explain it it's your baby
me and a bunch of other former
Republican guys who the the Liam Neeson
joke you know is a little tired but we
have a specific set of skills we do the
things that you talked about just now
about going after out of the dirty and
the dirty stuff well and it's the
affective stuff and it the effective and
it's it's the it's it's the group of us
that put it together we're gonna target
both Donald Trump and Donald Trump's
enablers now we're not trying to pick
the Democratic nominee we're not trying
to run their race or tell them how to do
their policy their ideology but as an
outside force that can do things that
that the Democrats have demonstrably
failed on doing a lot of the time like
actually getting in people [ __ ] we we're
sort of a pirate ship in that regard and
so we're gonna go at we're gonna go at a
lot of folks on their on their support
of Donald Trump we're gonna go a lot of
folks in the Senate who have now put
there and put their their heads on the
chopping block by following these votes
that are that basically empower Donald
Trump to be a lawless reckless corrupt
president so but will you put up a
candidate I think or didn't or you're
not gonna run a candidate there's
there's not a cannon you're not gonna
endorse we well that's that's a matter
we bill weld is running again
you know immaterial look there the math
doesn't exist right now for a Republican
candidate no in the primary and Donald
Trump has shut off all of the state
caucuses that matter are state primaries
that matter so you can't really get to
the nomination so we're on the outside
of that so we're gonna do as much as we
can to make sure that Donald Trump is
not reelected using all the tools in our
toolbox and some of them are pretty
freaking out
that's what do you think of the DNC
adjusting its debate qualifications is
it fair to the other candidates that
Bloomberg may be able to qualify I don't
think I think the rules ought to be the
same for everybody what they shouldn't
change him they set him they had a big
argument about him and they ought to
stay the way that they are Mayor
Bloomberg is is out there spending a ton
of money in areas that have not gone to
and doing a pretty good job from what I
can tell from read and enough yeah at
some point in time but I know there was
a dust-up with this early on about some
of the other candidates not being able
to get in and at some point in time I
suppose so but it's a really difficult
case for them to make today after taking
the position that they took a couple of
months I feel like when people lose they
just afraid about the rules yeah you
know anyways yeah I mean what do you
think about I mean cory booker dropped
down
qumola harvest dropped out and and there
was some support for that obvious and I
mean they were I didn't know what the
argument was because it's not like
they're in a party that isn't trying to
be diverse or that you know banned them
from the ballot box if they didn't get
the votes
yeah but they couldn't get in on
speaking of changing those rules they
couldn't get in on that right they would
like hey we have less than one
percentage we got to reach out to the
grassroots so the change the rules for
Bloomberg right now is kind of tricky
but I think now here's my theory
probably I'm the only person that thinks
this partly of the the blowback against
Kamala and Cory had nothing to do with
them they were perfectly fine candidates
I think it's the kind of delayed
reaction of grief over some Democrats to
Obama loved him as a person still a
great hero but his policies not so much
so they see a they see Kamala and Cory
who kind of look like Obama politically
speaking and they go yeah we've had that
enough and we need to go on to the next
one and that's my theory about why is
there that much disappointment about
Obama policies I mean saving the economy
bailing out the industry and you know
but health care I mean well but they
were they were complicated it's not just
policies right of the possible politics
well that's what people don't get these
days but but he went around the country
also picking on black
people in a particular kind of fashion
Obama did oh yeah picking on Vienna
like let me give a quick example so yeah
went to Morehouse College and he's
lecturing them and he's telling them
that they're graduating from college and
he's saying you know nobody's gonna give
you anything you didn't deserve her that
you didn't earn well the only person who
got an unearned degree that day was you
Obama because they work for theirs and
then he really kind of excoriated them
but in when he went to Barnard College
he had none of that so he was like I was
a young person I know what it is I
claimed the white man was being racist
against me I doubt that but then he
turns around and goes to burn it and
doesn't excoriate them for the sexism he
went to the Congressional Black Caucus
and said stop complaining stop bitching
put on your bedroom slippers go out
there in war because they were come they
were saying to him you got to have
policies that are at least more
respective of 14% black unemployment so
yeah I love the polling data reflects
that the Democrats in this country have
a very high opinion of President Obama's
tenure and they were taken back in a sec
all right thank you everybody
[Applause]
you